les exilés cubains en floride ils
attendent dans les services nantais
prochain réfugiés un certain froid entre
les européens et le gouvernement
américain après les reproches du
président carter jeux olympiques un pays
sur trois seulement a déjà accepté
l'invitation de moscou voilà monsieur
bonsoir des hommes et des femmes qui
vivent dans des conditions d'hygiène
dramatiques entassés dans un parc de
2000 mètres carrés seulement c'est la
situation actuelle des milliers de
cubains candidats à l'exil parquet dans
les jardins de l'ambassade du pérou à la
havane
autour d'eux des manifestations
incessantes de partisans du président
castro qui font monter la tension dans
cette affaire pour laquelle on ne voit
toujours pas de début de solution en
effet pour l'instant seul le pérou a en
principe décidé d'accueillir un millier
de réfugiés cubains et en europe seules
l'espagne et la république fédérale
allemande sont disposés à faire un geste
jacques séguin notre correspondant aux
états unis s'est rendu à miami en
floride à 80 km à peine de l'île de cuba
où vit la plus importante colonie
d'émigrés cubain qui suit heure par
heure l'évolution des événements
l'aqsiq
l'homme contre le mannequin le réfugié
cubain contre fidel castro le désir de
revanche et la nostalgie rassemble en ce
moment les foules de la pépite havana
miami
chaque soir à la tombée de la nuit ils
sont des milliers à crier leur haine et
leur frustration
on pense que la situation à couvin c'est
sous le mont ou manifestations dé la
situation d'ovale de l'économie et la
politique la vie à tout va la plupart
d'entre eux ou qui sait tout va il ya 20
ans n'ait conserver leur uniforme de la
guerre perdue pour venir en aide aux
10000 de la vanne certains ont commencé
lundi dernier une grève de la faim
mario se sauver du g20 il ya deux ans
sur une vieille barque de tai shan
100 km de la ville est resté toute sa
famille les 700000 cubains de miami
forment une communauté homogène qui a
ses centres d'accueil ses écoles ses
banques ses radios comme la faneuse w
cuba qu'on appelle ici la kubani cima 24
heures sur 24
elle rapporte les moindres événements de
l'ambassade du pérou à la fin quand on
dit que c'était à collecter l'équivalent
de deux super cargo de concert de
couverture et de lait en poudre
entreposée dans un gain d'une compagnie
privée mais qu'attendez-vous maintenant
vous qui êtes propriétaire de cette
compagnie le les permis pour le brancher
à coude à eau pour le venger à 0 à l'ida
il faut faire naturellement la part de
la création site latine dans ce
manifeste est donc la plus belle de
miami n'est pas le siège de l'analyse
ici on rejette castro globalement et on
trouve parfois des explications curieuse
aux événements de la main les coupables
c'est l'ayatollah voilà l'ayatollah le
prix alain il est le premier à les
nourrir et castrés ne tolère pas ça s'il
ne peut pas rester un des siens ils
doivent être toujours le premier c'est
un grand paranoïaque
j'ai vécu sa jeunesse je les connais
très bien et tant que les armes ne
pourront pas s'associer
il n'aura pas le prix pour lui tout ce
qui se passe c'est isoler les gens sont
désespérés pour partie le gars là pierre
n'importe où pour quitter le pays
et si el haouès formation donne un livre
fait il ne restera que tout seul avec
son frère 1 tout court à partir
malgré cet humour grinçant qui comme
chacun sait est la politesse du
désespoir
malgré les élans du coeur il ne fait pas
de doute que la crise ne peut se
résoudre de miami il est simplement que
tous les réfugiés pourraient être
accueillis et les problèmes économiques
qui n'épargne pas la floride
quant au gouvernement américain il reste
d'une très grande prudence il se
contente on y voit de souligner que
cette nouvelle affaire d'ambassade est
bien la preuve que je suis la révolution
de la havane à 20 ans elle a bien
vieilli et mal nos alliés nous demandent
de les aider
et lorsque nous avons besoin d'eux ils
revendiquent leur indépendance et
regrette notre ingérence alors que nous
demandons nous leur solidarité ainsi
peut-on résumer l'esprit des
déclarations faites la nuit dernière par
le président carter déçu par les
décisions prises par les européens hier
à lisbonne qui vont tenter les européens
une démarche auprès des autorités
iraniennes pour obtenir la libération
des otages sans pour autant lui emboîter
le pas des états unis dans le blocus
économique de l'iran aujourd'hui
monsieur carter a renouvelé cet appel à
la solidarité en recevant le maire de
berlin ouest en visite à washington
pourquoi le président américain se
montre-t-il aussi déçu de l'attitude des
européens
une question que je pose tout de suite à
monsieur simon serfaty quête en direct
avec nous de new york est un spécialiste
professeur de sciences politiques alors
pourquoi monsieur c'est reparti cette
déception de monsieur carter et bien
c'est une réaction une déception pour ne
pas dire une irritation en fait qui est
à la fois réel et en partie préfabriqués
elle est réelle dans la mesure où on
aurait pu s'attendre à une réaction à
des positions européennes qui aurait pu
être davantage positives davantage
constructive elle est pré fabriqué cette
déception du président carter dans la
mesure où dans une année électorale il
se doit de démontrer une certaine
fermeté non seulement vis-à-vis des
adversaires mais également vis-à-vis des
alliés est ce que l'on peut penser aux
états unis ce que l'on croit aux états
unis que les européens peuvent être
déconcerté par les différentes prises de
position de monsieur carter on peut en
être déconcerté
man dans une certaine mesure aux états
unis également certains publics ont fait
preuve de cette difficulté à suivre les
méandres de la position de
l'administration
néanmoins dans le cadre de l'alliance
d'un point de vue américain
nous pourrions nous attendre à davantage
de solidarité sur une question d'une
importance considérable aux états unis
mais ce que vous pouvez penser qu'en
europe on ne puisse ne plus avoir
confiance du tour monsieur carter qu'on
se demande un petit peu qu'est ce qui se
passe aux etats unis enfin à la tête des
états unis bien il n'y a vraiment aucune
alternative en ce moment à
l'administration des présidents carter
il faut lui faire confiance précisément
afin d'éviter l'escaladé d'une crise une
escalade qui aurait des conséquences
considérables pour les pays européens
aussi bien que pour nous mêmes mais sur
quoi peut-on ceux basés en europe pour
faire confiance au président carter qui
avance qui recule dans les différentes
affaires comme l'afghanistan et puis
ensuite l'iran s'il me fallait à
identifier une base qui permettrait une
confiance de ce genre alors je
choisirais la patience dont le président
a fait preuve ces six derniers mois
il va sans dire que cette crise aurait
pu être est ce qu'elle est est-ce
qu'elle avait considérablement dès les
premières heures de la prise d otages
le président a démontré un certain calme
a démontré une certaine patience a
démontré un certain engagement quant à
la résolution pacifique de ce problème
mais il ne faut pas penser néanmoins que
les otages américains vont établir
résidence de façon permanente en iran et
à l'intérieur de l'ambassade mais
injustement la question qu'on se pose en
europe c'est pourquoi le président
carter n'a rien fait depuis le début de
cette affaire contrairement à ce que
vous venez de dire pourquoi n'at-il pas
agi c'est une des questions qu'on se
pose certaines actions ont été élaborés
en janvier par exemple vous vous en
souvenez on avait déjà commencé à
définir certaines actions qu'elle est
dans la direction qui a été ré
adapté erea adoptée dans les jours
passés
néanmoins vers la fin janvier les
autorités à téhéran avait semblé
démontré une bonne volonté quant à la
résolution et voilà relâche rapide de
ces otages
ceux qui avaient quelque peu retardé
l'implémentation de ces décisions
une dernière question sur faty est ce
que cette affaire peut amener la perte
aux élections de monsieur carter face à
monsieur kennedy où monsieur reagan face
à monsieur kennedy et cela est très
douteux en fin de compte le président a
accumulé une quantité considérable de
délégués qui devront voter pour lui au
moins au premier tour de la convention
du parti des démocrates en juillet août
prochain quant à l'élection vis-à-vis de
président vis-à-vis le gouverneur regen
cela est difficile à dire tout dépend de
la façon dont cette crise évoluera dans
les jours dans les semaines dans les
mois à venir
merci beaucoup je vous le dis tout de
suite dans notre dernier journal ce soir
alain duhamel reviendra sur cette
affaire iranienne et le différend entre
l'europe et les états unis sur cette
question d'ajouter encore deux
informations à propos de l'iran le
ministre des affaires étrangères
français monsieur jean françois-poncet
estime que les positions française et
européenne dans l'affairé iranienne sont
exemple d'ambiguïté condamnation de la
prise d'otages démarches pour obtenir la
libération des diplomates américains
enfin le ministre a indiqué que la
france répondrait à la demande du
président carter de s'associer aux
sanctions contre l'iran mais il n'a pas
été fixé de délai pour cette réponse est
qu une dépêche qui vient de tomber
indique que les ambassadeurs européens
seront reçus demain à téhéran par le
président de la république iranienne
monsieur bani sadr et puis encore à
téhéran une manifestation regroupant
environ un million de personnes a eu
lieu aujourd'hui pour démontrer l'unité
du peuple iranien dans les différentes
affaires engagé le président bani sadr a
prononcé un discours dans lequel il s'en
est pris essentiellement à l'irak qui a
depuis une semaine qui est depuis une
semaine en conflit larvé avec l'iran à
propos d'un différend territorial
les jeux olympiques de moscou c'était
aussi un des thèmes du discours de la
nuit dernière
carter le président américain semble
prêt à tout pour que ces athlètes
n'aille pas en urss pour l'instant à 100
jours de l'ouverture de ces jeux
seulement 40 comités nationaux sur 143
ont répondu favorablement à l'invitation
de moscou pour se déterminer
la plupart des autres attendent
principalement la décision du comité
olympique américain qui pèsera lourd
dans la balance ce comité doit se réunir
demain serge riches
le comité olympique américain va se
réunir dès ce soir et pourrait se
prononcer demain à moins qu'ils ne
repoussent au 24 mai date limite d
engagement sa décision
le moins qu'on puisse dire est que la
position du comité américain est très
inconfortable car il est l'objet de
multiples pressions des pressions qui se
sont terriblement accentuée cette
semaine
d'un côté les athlètes qui à 85 %
souhaitent participer aux jeux
olympiques
néanmoins ils sont prêts à composer oui
aux épreuves sportives non aux
cérémonies officielles essentiellement
instituée par la traditionnelle remise
des médailles
face à cette volonté le refus du
président carter qui sont plus par la
presse et l'opinion publique et
fermement décidés à s'opposer par tous
les moyens à la présence américaine à
moscou le président carter a déclaré je
suis prête à utiliser tous les pouvoirs
légaux dont je dispose l'administration
américaine pourrait révoquer les
passements et sélectionné olympique ou
appliquée sur ses paroles un cachet
interdisant de se rendre en urss
demain matin avant même que les délégués
du comité ne se prononcent contre la
participation messieurs walter mondale
vice président des états unis
s'adressera aux comités olympiques et
plaidera une dernière fois en faveur du
boycott
révélation de la nature des sanctions
pour empêcher tout athlète américain de
participer aux jeux olympiques
harcèlement par les discours de
recommandation
le processus de chute libre des jeux
olympiques est inéluctablement engage
la france défend l'europe c'est l'une
des phrases clés de l'interview du
président la république monsieur giscard
d'estaing au figaro aujourd'hui à la
veille du sommet européen de luxembourg
le président de la république n'entend
pas à ramener les problèmes actuels de
l'europe à un simple différend entre la
france et la grande bretagne le
commentaire de philippe harrouard face
aux remous actuels
l'heure est-elle bien choisi d' étaler
nos divisions demande le chef de l'état
question qui s'adresse surtout à la
grande bretagne dont les revendications
concernant sa contribution risque de
paralyser la communauté pour monsieur
giscard d'estaing il y a deux hypothèses
ou bien la grande bretagne réclament un
allègement provisoire est limitée de sa
contribution et il est normal que ses
partenaires l'aide ou bien elle veut une
modification du traité de rome et c'est
une toute autre affaire
modifier le traité de rome c'est un
large débat qui intéresse les neuf
pour sa part monsieur giscard d'estaing
pense que ce n'est pas le moment de
revenir sur des institutions qui
fonctionnent depuis 20 ans le président
de la république explique pourquoi il
est partisan de régler en même temps les
autres problèmes fixation des prix
agricoles dossier du mouton et de la
pêche parce qu'il serait illogique de
geler les problèmes qui concernent la
vie quotidienne de la communauté alors
que la grande bretagne réclament une
dérogation qui coûtera de l'argent à ses
partenaires enfin monsieur giscard
d'estaing regrette que les sommets
européens soient détournées de leur but
initial qui est une réflexion commune
des dirigeants sur les grands problèmes
de l'heure et non la recherche de
solutions techniques
si à luxembourg comme à dublin il y à un
pass à cause de la contribution
britannique est bien dit le chef de
l'état
il faudra appliquer les règles
communautaires telles qu'elles existent
façon de dire que la balle se trouve
dans le camp des anglais
l'année dernière le commerce en france a
connu un taux de croissance compris
entre 2 et 2 et demi pour cent c'est ce
qu'indique une étude de l'insee
l'institut national de la statistique
si le commerce de gros a connu une
croissance comprise entre 2 5 et 3%
c'est le commerce de détail qui a le
plus souffert de la crise économique
avec un taux de croissance de seulement
1 5%
et puis une autre enquête de l'insee
montrent qu'en 1979 le pouvoir d'achat
des fonctionnaires a b
de 1,3 pour cent ce sont les plus gros
salaires qui perdent le plus les plus
bas conservant leur pouvoir d'achat les
français épargnent moins le mouvement
s'amplifie et ce n'est pas sans rapport
avec la situation économique que je
viens d'évoquer les dépôts sur les
livrets à de caisse d'epargne de
l'écureuil ont diminué de 68 millions de
francs en mars pour la première fois
depuis 15 ans en cette période de
l'année
les français ont donc retiré plus
d'argent qu'ils n'en n'ont dépose
jean-marc hills
ce phénomène de baisse du niveau de
l'épargné liquide était perceptible
depuis l'année dernière
depuis le début de l'année il s'est
brusquement amplifié certes les français
continuent d'épargner et les dépôts
restent excédentaires mais pour le
réseau écureuils par exemple 17 millions
de clients
ces excédents seront pour le premier
trimestre 80 inférieur de plus de 60% à
leur niveau de 1979
alors pourquoi cette chute brutale je
crois qu'on peut l'attribuer
essentiellement à l'inflation qui
malheureusement ravage notre pays depuis
quelques mois qui a impliqué une baisse
de ressources d'une part pour les
épargnants et d'autre part pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux désireux de
continuer à conserver leur niveau de vie
une augmentation des dépenses ce qui
finalement s'est traduit par une
certaine baisse de la progression des
dépôts dans les caisses d'epargne
d'autre part il faut bien signalé le
taux d'intérêt jusqu'au 1er avril
méritait d'être reconsidérée vous pensez
que la hausse de 1% récente suffire à
renverser la tendance
je pense que ce sera un facteur
déterminant de renversement de tendance
tout au moins après quelques semaines un
facteur suffisant pour vous permettre de
prêter de l'argent facilement dans les
mois qui suivent nous l'espérons mais
nous n'en sommes pas certains nous
pensons véritablement que pour être en
mesure d'assurer les prêts aux
collectivités locales d'une part et aux
particuliers d'autre part ce relèvement
du taux d'intérêt devrait être
accompagnée d'une modification du
plafond
le plafond dont nous avons demandé le
relèvement depuis un certain temps est
resté stable malheureusement trop
longtemps et nous espérons pourtant que
d'ici l'été
ils pourraient être remontés au moins
jusqu'à 52 mille francs une vingtaine de
députés en séance beaucoup de
journalistes femmes dans les tribunes et
toute une classe d'adolescents ainsi se
composait cet après midi l'assistance
qui a suivi le débat sur le viol engagé
à l'assemblée nationale cela dit sur le
plan politique ce qui est à remarquer
c'est l'accord de principe sur ce projet
entre toutes les formations de
l'opposition et de la majorité c'est ce
que vous avez constaté daniel way nous
avons effectivement entendu tout l'après
midi une série d'hymnes à la gloire de
la femme du respect de sa dignité et de
sa liberté sur ce point aucune
discordance harmonie également pour la
définition du crime de viol
qu'ils soient commis contre un homme ou
contre une femme il est désormais
passible de la cour de cassation et plus
de la correctionnelle enfin unanimité
également pour protéger les victimes
contre toute publicité malsaine et pour
les encourager donc à déposer plainte
les intéressés pourront enfin demandé le
huis clos des débats de obtenir que leur
nom ne soit pas cité et que leur
anonymat soit protégé même dans
n'importe quel livre ou une brochure et
enfin les médecins avec l'accord de la
victime pour en porter à la connaissance
de la justice
les violences corps ont subi leur
patiente ceci bien sûr par le canal des
parquets
merci daniel mais j'ai autre chose à
dire en ce qui concerne les peines je
pensais que vous allez me demander s'il
n'a fait l'unanimité jusqu'au bout le
désaccord a porté sur l'échelle des
peines l'opposition voulait cinq à dix
ans de réclusion criminelle et la
majorité a maintenu 10 à 20 ans et en
cas de circonstances aggravantes
et bien c'est pas nous irons jusqu'à la
réclusion perpétuelle
alors c'est à l'occasion d'un du délit
d'attentât à la pudeur que l'on a vu
s'opposer à ces vivement monsieur foyer
et monsieur forni et françaises qui
socialiste l'opposition en effet au nom
de la liberté sexuelle voulait supprimer
je cite les brimades contre les
homosexuels
la majorité a été d'accord en ce qui
concernait les adultes mais l'a
maintenue toutes les peines
en ce qui concerne les délits à
l'encontre des mineurs à vous cette fois
cognacq-jay merci daniel gillet plus de
questions à vous poser
le sondage mensuel ifop france soir le
président de la république perd deux
points par rapport au mois dernier 45%
de satisfaits contre 47 il y à un mois
les mécontents augmente de 5 % 42 contre
37 le premier ministre monsieur bart est
lui aussi en baisse d'un point
30% de satisfaits contre 56 % de
mécontents général de gaulle avait remis
son testament à monsieur pompidou et ne
lui a jamais retiré c'est ce qu'affirme
dans l'express de cette semaine madame
marie-france garaud qui fut l'une des
plus proches collaboratrices du
président pompidou puis de monsieur
jacques chirac plus qu'en juin dernier
madame garraud qui s'indignent donc à
son tour de la campagne actuelle qui se
développe autour de monsieur pompidou et
de ses démêlés d'aimer les éventuels
avec le général de gaulle madame figaro
qui affirme également ne plus faire de
politique et puis dans la sphère de
breuil
ce soir les communistes le groupe
communiste de l'assemblée nationale a
décidé de saisir le bureau de
l'assemblée pour entamer une procédure
de mise en accusation devant la haute
cour de justice de monsieur poniatowski
c'est au bureau de l'assemblée qui va se
réunir de déterminer si elle accepte oui
ou non si elle déclare cette demande
recevable
l'espace ne fait plus la une de
l'actualité mais les expériences se
poursuivre
l'union soviétique vient de réussir la
jonction entre le vaisseau spatial
soyouz 35 et sa lieu de 6 à bord de
l'engin
1 le recordman de la durée dans l'espace
riou mines qui restait retenez bien ce
chiffre cent soixante quinze jours dans
l'espace en 1979
mais les russes ne se contente pas de
faire des expériences spectaculaires il
semble préparer des armes spatiales
destinées à détruire les satellites
philippe duez l'union soviétique a
actuellement une activité débordante
dans l'espace
deux cosmonautes papou ferry aux mines
sont partis à bord du vaisseau cosmique
soyouz 35 pour aller rejoindre la
station orbitale
saliou ciss cette station tourne autour
de la terre depuis plus de deux ans et
demi elle est approvisionné lorsque des
cosmonautes se trouve à bord par des
vaisseaux de transport automatique
programme
la mission des deux cosmonautes est
d'abord de vérifier le bon état de
l'ensemble du train spatial qui avait eu
des problèmes d'arrimage avec une autre
station ça use 33
ensuite pop up your mean devront
accomplir un programme scientifique
d'observation de la terre d'expérience
technique est astronomique
d'après les américains l'union
soviétique se préparerait également à
lancer un satellite antisatellites le 3
avril dernier les soviétiques ont lancé
un engin spatial qui pourrait bien être
une cible pour à cette élite tueur qui
sera lancée ultérieurement une
expérience semblable avait déjà eu lieu
en mai 78 et elle avait réussi ces
satellites tueurs sont destinés à
détruire les satellites espions qui sert
temps à l'urss qu'aux états unis à se
surveiller mutuellement
des pourparlers sont en cours pour
interdire ces armes spatiales mais elles
n'ont pas encore abouti
les américains pour leur part ne veulent
pas prendre de retard dans ce domaine
puisqu'ils viennent de doubler le budget
de ce secteur pour l'année prochaine
tous ces satellites seront automatiques
et dirigé de la terre ce sera donc une
guerre de machines mais attention aux
retombées souvenez-vous des morceaux de
satellites qui sont retombés sur terre
l'année dernière ce ne sera pas toujours
dans les régions désertiques
monsieur poma si vous étiez l'un des
invités aujourd'hui d'antenne de midi
l'invité de monsieur m'a lory ethnologue
qui est un spécialiste de la
civilisation et screamo qui était le
témoin du journal d'aujourd'hui si nous
avons demandé de revenir ce soir ce qui
n'est pas notre habitude c'est que votre
expérience nous a semblé
particulièrement passionnant intéressant
monsieur poma si vous avez quitté le
togo à 16 ans pour le groenland alors
j'ai qu'une seule question à vous poser
pourquoi le togo le groenland
oui un effet si la question est bien
venu et comme je disais ce midi c'est un
l'ag de 16 ans que j'ai lu pour la
première fois un livre sur les sur le
blanc l1 et je n'avais jamais pensé
qu'il pouvait y avoir un peuple vivant
dans deux maisons construites avec de la
neige ne savais même pas ce que c'était
la neige la glace un pays où les
montagnes était de glace alors que chez
nous
il fallait rouvrir un frigidaire pour
voir de petits pubs des glaçons et que
c'est assez a dit ces gens mangeaient
cru et vivait et sur un rythme
absolument différent du nôtre deuxième
question tout aussi simple quels ont été
vos premières impressions
mes premières impressions les premières
impressions des disques immo et nous
voyant oui eux évidemment n'avait jamais
n'avait jamais touché si l'on peut dire
un noir il savait que les noirs vivent
équidés m'arriver quelque part et dans
leur mythologie même tous ceux qui les
tenait pas eskimos est un une sorte de
bâtard fils de d'une femme et d'un chien
c'est l'idée que les eskimos se faisait
du de scott pour la pole aujourd'hui
cash flow naksa 10 des gens qui viennent
du sud
et quand les petits grolandais m'ont vu
débarquer je vous dis je vous assure que
je peux pas vous décrire la panique qui
c'est qui s'est emparée d'eux je me suis
préparé dans ma cabine du bateau et je
descend lentement la passerelle à
travers le hublot j'avais déjà j'avais
vu la population sur le port en train de
commenter
le bateau qui vient qui venait
ravitailler et quand ils m'ont vu
soudain d'abord il y a eu tant de mal à
10 ans tous cessé de parler lui un reer
figé et je saurai plus tard ils m'ont
pris pour un farceur un blanc décrit un
être en blanc mais qui sait qui c'est un
monsieur peu massy et qu'est ce qui va
se passer maintenant pour vous je crois
savoir que vous avez demander la
naturalisation vous voulez devenir un
citoyen du grenelle soit faire
absolument vous savez quand on a engagé
douze années de sa vie dans un voyage
comme celui que j'ai fait il a fallu que
de pays en pays
je paye mon propre voyage que je finance
mon voyage
et quand on a investi 12 années de sa
vie dans un pays je crois que on devient
passionnément amoureux de du pays en
question et c'est mon cas et une autre
motivation est le fait que la france à
ces assauts chamailleries brillante
ethnologue à 100 paul emile victor à son
art ou tazieff
et malheureusement l'afrique manque de
gens et ayant rien il ya une certaine
volonté de réaliser nous les onze
quelque sorte de venir le paul emile
victor du togo et de l'afrique le mois
peut-être aux formes et cède ses données
à mes compatriotes africains
un exemple je veux être un modèle un
modèle bien si vous hier dans notre
journal nous vous présentions un extrait
d'une nouvelle chanson dans laquelle le
charles aznavour accompagner les paroles
avec le langage gestuel des sourds qu'il
avait spécialement appris à cette
occasion et bien ce soir c'est un autre
spectacle original que nous vous
invitons à suivre au théâtre de la ville
un corps de ballet israéliens
connaissent actuellement un large succès
sa particularité la moitié des danseurs
sont des sourds un reportage de olga
polyakov et frédéric vaast
cole de mama signifie en hébreu sont des
silences
on
plus
il est sourd et ils dansent
m
autour de lui d'autres sources mais
aussi des entendants
pour suivre le rythme les vibrations et
mais un entendant en tapant du pied sur
le sol
à
et moshé frati qui dirige son ballet des
coulisses lesourd reçoit le son par
l'intermédiaire de celui qui entend
regarder aucune différence entre celui
qui entend et celui qui n'entend pas son
et silence la météo ont rapidement pour
terminer demain après quelques brumes
matinales localiser surtout dans l'est
et le nord-est le ciel se dégagera on
notera cependant des nuages passagers
sur les régions voisines de l'atlantique
les températures assez basses dans la
matinée seront en hausse sensible dans
la journée tout va bien il y avait du
soleil aujourd'hui il y en aura encore
demain dernier journal ce soir hervé
claude demain samedi ennemis présentée
par georges bigot en direct de beaune à
l'occasion des journées nationales en
milieu rural
invités monsieur jean philippe lecat
ministre de la culture et de la
communication et puis demain soir à ma
place léon zitrone je crois que
n'oublier personne je vous souhaite
simplement maintenant une excellente
soirée sur antenne 2 bonsoir